before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
no matter what you think about a
situation
there's always nuance
[Music]
so with the ever more imminent end of
the chris chibnall and jody whitaker era
of doctor who i feel like it's
maybe overdue for me to
well
kind of defend chibno a little bit
now
let me be clear
my thoughts on chibnall and his era are
not only pretty well documented at this
point they are continuing to be
documented as i do my re-watch of series
11 and then probably series 12 soon
after that
so
i'm not here to tell you that this stuff
was secretly great because
i don't think that
i do however think that especially among
people who dislike this era there are
things that are
worth taking into account there were
decisions made and aspects to the
approach that chavnil took
that i think were not only defensible
but good ideas at least on paper
even if the execution didn't pull it
through and i want to give credit where
credit's due and also account for some
of the difficulties in a way that maybe
i haven't up to this point
now part of this is inspired by an
interview that chris chibnall gave with
the radio times which was brought to my
attention by uh mr tardis um i am
cribbing a little bit from his video on
the piece so maybe check that out and
throw them throw them a few views uh i
promise i didn't just lift the entire
thing
but the simple truth is that there are
certain aspects to how chipnel approach
things that i think have either not been
known or have been criticized by fans
that i don't think is fair
and i'm going to be kind of jumping
around on this but
one of the first things i want to tackle
is i think there are
those uh among us especially who
wanted to like his era and
didn't
being
very frustrated that
there didn't seem to be much adjustment
for what things the
audience was saying was or wasn't
working
so
to address that chibnall said flat out
he
ignored the fandom now
there are those who would point to that
as a mark of criticism for chimnal that
well this is why everything failed he
wasn't listening to the fans except uh
he also notes that not listening to the
fans was a piece of advice given to him
by both
russell t davis and stephen moffat
neither of them listened to fans either
and they advised him not to now
understand listening to fans doesn't
mean necessarily aggressively ignoring
them but just not going on fan forms not
watching the reviews if you have
something you intend to do
do that thing and not only is that a
piece of creative advice that i think
generally makes sense
it makes more sense for chibnall than
for either of the other two here's what
i mean by that
chibno
came in wanting to do
some pretty
large scale things he obviously was
planning stuff
to pay off down the line now we could
argue all day over how well that did or
didn't work but the simple truth is the
very notion of the timeless child and or
hidden secrets about the doctor was
planted in the very second episode of
his era
even though it wouldn't pay off until
the finale of the following series well
i say payoff it wouldn't get explained
i'm not sure it has paid off but it did
okay i'm i'm trying to not let my
criticisms uh
bleed into this too much but the thing
is if you're planning on telling a
continuous story if you have a an idea
for something long term
it's even more important that you not
get bogged down in the audience feedback
and what they think is going to happen
or what they think should happen
because that's how you get game of
thrones season eight
and nobody wants game of thrones season
eight
i suppose i should give context for that
just a little bit on the off chance that
people don't quite know the connection
so game of thrones season eight was
really bad on a lot of levels but one of
the big ones was that there were a whole
bunch of story and character turns that
seemed to exist for absolutely no reason
other than it wasn't what the audience
was expecting and it was very clear that
the two guys who were running that
series had been paying a lot of
attention to what the fans were saying
thinking and more damningly speculating
and they seemed to go out of their way
to just do things that would be
unexpected for their own sake the
problem is if you're telling a long
continuous story and you've done the job
decently the reason fans are speculating
a certain outcome
is because that's what you've been
building towards and so subverting that
isn't a surprise it's just wait what or
as the writer of the original book uh
george rr martin himself put it if
you've planned your book that the butler
did it
and then you read an internet someone
has figured out that the butler did it
and you suddenly change in mid stream
and it was the chambermaid who did it
then
you screw up the whole book because you
get these just foreshadowing early on
and you've got these little clues you
planted now they're dead ends and you
have to introduce other clues and you're
retconning it's a mess so yeah if you're
trying to tell a longer term story even
if it's not completely serialized the
way game of thrones was it's probably
important that you not get bogged down
in
fan response and reaction i mean heck
i'd actually argue it would have made
more sense for either
rtd or moffitt to pay more attention to
the fans since they were doing
completely well more or less completely
self-contained series
so by the time they got a response to
say
series 3 or series 6 it's already done
and shot and the next series is going to
be its own thing so i would actually
argue that it might not be the end of
the world for either one of those two to
look into the criticisms or the praises
and see what was work or what was going
to work and what wasn't because it
wasn't going to necessarily directly
impact intended story beats and that's
before we even get into the toxicity and
the fact that chibnall was getting death
threats over the unforgivable sin of
envisioning the doctor as someone
without a penis
at least we think the doctor doesn't
have a penis actually we don't really
know what time lords have going on in
the downstairs department
that was a presumption on my end huh
you know what i mean though
so and i'm not going to dig into that
anymore i don't i don't want this video
to be about
toxic fandoms but you add that on top of
it it's super understandable that he was
not paying attention to the fan
communities i think that was honestly
not only a good choice creatively but
absolutely good choice for probably his
own mental health
and no matter who you are whether you're
praising or criticizing
you need to respect the fact that it's
not good for creators to just be
bombarded with feedback
so yeah that's a very defensible choice
also let's just briefly touch on the
notion of the fact that he wanted story
things to go over a longer term than
just from series to series that was a
new direction and i think one worth
exploring again
i don't think he explored it very well
but as i said under both rtd and moffat
series were pretty solidly
self-contained entities
you know there was a story arc of that
series it ended we move on to the next
very few major plot points would carry
over siri to series to series
so to
take a situation where like okay we're
gonna plant some ideas here we're not
even gonna touch them until the next
series
that was a new way of approaching it and
coming in with newer ways to do it which
i would also include things like we're
going to do the first series with no
returning uh major villains it's going
to be all self-contained we're going to
try it with three companions these are
all
solid enough ideas ways to shake it up
that aren't
inherently so disruptive that it breaks
the format but our different ways of
doing it that we haven't had in the
modern era
again i don't think most of them worked
but i don't think there's anything wrong
with these ideas inherently and i think
some of them are even good i've said in
the past especially with series 11 on
paper a lot of what chibnall did is what
i would have asked for i would have
asked for more self-contained stuff less
reliance on returning classic villains
this was stuff i myself might have even
said we should do that if i was in
charge of the show
and then he did those things and again
but
i think
whatever strengths chipnel has i think
most of them are in his broad stroke
ideas
and most of the issues tend to come in
execution
but let's
talk about that execution a little bit
because i think one of the things this
actually exposes a weakness on for
something that we're about to get into
is that when you make plans to plant
something now that you're not even going
to pay off until
next series
that unfortunately
opens up the possibility that
something's going to go wrong that
throws your entire thing out of whack
hence
covid
now the biggest uh impact of covid was
on flux uh series 13.
there is
very little doubt that covet had a
massive impact probably on the number of
episodes definitely on the way they were
written so that they could be shot in a
way as coveted uh compliant as
possible and
it does really and there's a lot of
indicators that make it appear very
strongly that the intention was to have
more episodes than this
but
just things fell apart ed heim who wrote
episodes both for series 11 and series
12 one of my favorite episodes in series
11 and one of the worst episodes of
series 12. talk about a roller coaster
with this guy he had i don't think he
said he'd finish the script but he
definitely had a full pitch for a story
and was working on a full script for
series 13
but it was scrapped because
with the way they were going to have to
shoot and the number of episodes they
were actually going to get
that episode simply didn't happen and
looking at flux itself it is very clear
that some of those episodes
were more or less intended to be
self-contained the big uh giveaways
being uh the sontaran episode and the
one with the weeping angels
which are also the two strongest of that
series although i didn't like the
weeping angels one but i still think
it's more solid than a lot of what else
is there but it's very clear that those
were probably meant to be standalone
pieces that had the flux overarching
narrative grafted onto them and the fact
that it was grafted onto them so it
means that this was scrambling probably
pretty late in the game now
i have criticized in the past that even
knowing those restrictions i still feel
like this is
sloppily put together and i do stand by
that however it is worth acknowledging
these are massive complications
not only of changing how what it is you
think you can do with the series but
taking you from a position of thinking
you're going to have more time more
episodes and just a more relaxed
shooting environment as an opportunity
to tell your story and having pretty
much all of that scrapped on you the
fact that flux was made at all is kind
of a miracle
again the actual
results aren't great it would be an
amazing story if flux was good
like if flux actually worked all the way
through which i know for some people at
least it did for me it really didn't but
if it like really nailed it this would
be a story of absolute creative triumph
under all these restrictions and
sometimes that happens sometimes the way
things go wrong forces really innovative
and unique creative solutions that make
something better
but more commonly when things go wrong
you can tell that something went wrong
and i think that's very much the case
with flux but i bring it up because
he made that series especially and also
uh the specials lest we forget under
way less than ideal circumstances
that's something that i failed to
acknowledge even when i did my full
breakdown on flux and how did it end up
this way i mostly focused on
how the apparent compacting of the
series really did the story no favors at
all and
i think i really only did kind of a
token acknowledgement of how
difficult and how restrictive and how
much of a moving target
figuring that stuff out was i still
stand by every single criticism that i
made
but i could have been a heck of a lot
more fair in acknowledging
exactly what the constraints were like
what kind of pressure this thing was
under and it's probably been a similar
case for the specials like the legend of
the sea devils is barely longer than a
standard episode and there is word that
like nearly 15 minutes were cut from it
why and at what point in the process i
don't know i don't know if it was
something that they were told before
they even started shooting but after
they had a script if it was something
they were told while they were in the
middle of editing the dang thing
who knows but like
stuff really seems to keep going wrong
and
one of the most frustrating things that
i'll see is i'll see
people who
have a conspiratorial bent to their
content accuse chibnall of trying to
purposefully sabotage the show if anyone
is purposely sabotaging the show it's
the bbc as a whole not cri not chris
chibnall in specific and i'm not saying
the bbc is purposely sabotaging doctor
who but i am saying that the decisions
being made at a higher level than chris
jamil had control over by the bbc were
detrimental to this show that i think is
kind of indisputable and the other thing
is
for as much as i
have and will continue to criticize this
era of doctor who
it's gotten us some good stuff
some good characters
some good beats some good episodes even
if i'm gonna say in defense of chris
chibnall i should probably cite some
specific things that i really enjoy
there are specific characters and
casting decisions that i think work
really well
graham was great dan i ended up liking a
heck of a lot more than i thought
considering i really desperately did not
want another
modern time companion to be joining i
especially didn't want another one
joining in on yaz and the doctor when i
wanted to see that relationship be built
up more but
i like dan he won me over i really like
sasha dewan as the master i
love joe martin as the fugitive doctor
which is another thing that i think kind
of suffered under the
changing in shooting how many episodes
they were going to get the way they had
to shoot etc
i have little doubt that
there was an original plan to do a lot
more with the fugitive doctor than we
got and i want
i wanted and i still want so much more
from her
but
you know after series 12 introduced her
if she was supposed to show up more in
flux and or after that
well
everything i've already talked about
with the shooting of flux we've even had
some good villains i really like ashad
i think he's a fantastic concept and an
amazing performance he's a really good
villain and i'm kind of excited that
we're going to see him again in the
final episode now
if i'm being honest most of my favorite
episodes of this era
weren't written by chibnall at least not
on his own they were either written by
other people or were co-written by
chibnall but
that having been said they were still
made under his tenure as show runner he
fostered these stories he helped them
come about so he deserves at least some
credit for the fact that i got things
like it takes you away
can you hear me war of the centaurus
honestly even eve at the daleks i think
that's probably the best one that he
himself wrote it was fun and energetic
and a neat use of a time loop which is
something that doctor who has not done
very much you think it would have been a
time travel show but
that was good
war of the sun tyrants might honestly be
my favorite sontaran specific story of
the modern era the idea of using the
historical settings to put more of a
focus on eras and the things going on on
a bigger scale and a little bit less
emphasis on individuals even though a
lot of times they were still there i
think that's the case with rosa that's
definitely the case with demons of the
punjab and look don't get me wrong
i'm not sad he's leaving
that that was never in the cards but you
know given the fact that i've spent the
last three or four years largely bashing
on the guy
i think it would be unfair for me not to
acknowledge
there's been some good here and that
some of the things he tried
are things i probably would have tried
and or support in theory even if the
execution wasn't there
i don't think that about every decision
he made but
it's important to be fair
so i call this a defense of chris
chibnall
i mean maybe it's not really maybe it's
more of a
let's be fair to chris chibnall
but that's not a nice clickbaity title
so i couldn't go with that
but yeah
i [ __ ] a lot
on this channel i know that
especially when it comes to doctor who i
can be real picky but
i don't want anyone to ever forget that
i love this show
and there have been moments within
even chibnall's time that i have loved
so in the spirit of positivity
what is your favorite thing about
chibnalzera
it can be a bit of casting specific
episode specific general idea it can
even be something that you love that i
hate it's all on the table whatever you
think was good
about his time as showrunner
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it oh and please don't
be the needless contrarian who's just
gonna go there was nothing good like
work with me in the spirit of this okay
if that's all you've got to say just
don't
but uh
i do wanna hear your thoughts
i wanna know what people liked
whether it's what i liked or not
if you want to support what i can do
patreon is how i make my living and i'm
able to do this full-time as my job any
amount you can contribute helps but
there are other things you can do as
well like share subscribe help out this
channel quite a bit the algorithm is
very up and down on me lately uh it
hasn't been consistent for me in a while
um but also there's other things you can
check me out and i'm on twitch tiktok
instagram i have books for sale
fictional and non-fiction
but uh
you don't have to worry too much
about any of that
because what i really want you to
remember
in the spirit of positivity
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
and credits i gotta shout out my top
patreon supporters so thank you very
much to zubin luthfulla barack oliver
bean melinda walters lyotha boy tt for
knobby lax the poodle idol tracy
scrabbat vincent paul bartolucci angry
casper adam lefty taylor shane ross
robin moore shayla gourlay and brendan
the rose
couldn't do it without you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]